as author Jenny harness said PS I still
love you is about the reality of really
loving somebody and not just falling in
love with somebody this is the part of
the story that you often don't get to
see in movies which is what happens
after the couple gets together upk we be
lovers I'm Jon and in this video I'm
breaking down how LJ made her crucial
decision at the end of PS I still love
you there will of course be spoilers so
take care if you haven't seen the movie
yet LJ may be deliriously happy at the
prospect of their first date but reality
doesn't quite live up to the fantasy of
her romance novels and things don't turn
out quite as perfectly as she imagined
Lara Jean finds Peters goofing around at
the restaurant a little embarrassing and
the moment feels life special when she
discovers he regularly took his ex
Genevieve to the same restaurant for
every first I was having with him he'd
already had his with her
LJ also feels let down by Peter when she
finds out that the Valentine's Day poem
she thought he'd written specially for
her was actually written by Edgar Allan
Poe and then there's the way Peter turns
of hours late for a coffee date with LJ
as he prioritized sports practice over
her but the issues they're having with
their relationship aren't entirely on
Peter
because when Lara Jean unexpectedly
receives the letter from childhood
crushed John Ambrose emotions of feeling
she didn't expect to have any longer
rush back to the surface I thought
having a boyfriend meant the mere idea
of other boys left your mind completely
as Lana Condor who plays LJ told aw John
is kind of like the male version of Lara
Jean everything she loves he loves for
example they're both house Hufflepuff
which LJ once thought could be a sign
they were destined for each other
Laura Jean doesn't know how to handle
these old feelings and memories and
tries to suppress them by putting away
the letter she's writing to John Ambrose
oh my god I cannot do this too I have to
tell Peter about this but when she meets
him again and reads her original
childhood letter which mentions their
shared embarrassment during a Halloween
party she remembers how close she felt
to him he'll have you Tony Ambrose I
really love you I'll always know that
once upon a time my heart was yours as
she explores these emotions Laura Jean
realizes she feels much more comfortable
around John compared
the constant whirring she feels and
overthinking she does about her
relationship with Peter what a Peter
we're sitting here and we were sharing
an ice-cream sandwich all right I'd be
thinking about
has Peter shared an ice-cream sandwich
with someone before does he think that
I'm a prude if I just want to share an
ice-cream sandwich I just need a break
from the contortions of being someone's
girlfriend the developing love triangle
creates problems of Peter and LJ's
relationship when he gets jealous that
she's spending time with John Ambrose at
Bellevue it's no coincidence that this
comes up in the middle of a biology
class during which the teacher talks
about octopuses having three hearts and
there's a clever bit of foreshadowing of
their breakup when Lara Jean died sex
the octopuses heart in front of a
squeamish Peter things come to a head at
their old treehouse haunt where Peter
gets possessive and John finds out that
LJ and Peter are together something she
hadn't told him
Peter complains LJ shouldn't be hanging
around with her ex crush an accusation
that seems a bit rich given the amount
of time he spends with Jenn although
they patched things up they argue again
later about Peter's close relationship
with Jan and LJ has the heartbreaking
realization that on the night of the hot
tub Peter was actually waiting for Jenn
not her
LJ's mistrust of Peter is too deep and
they break up at the aquarium which was
hinted at earlier during the octopus
heart scene ultimately the roots of
their problem is the secrets have been
keeping from each other their intentions
weren't necessarily bad as each was
trying to protect the other Peter keeps
the time he spends with Jenn trying to
help her with their parents problem
hidden from Laura Jean because he knows
there's bad blood between them and
likewise LJ keeps her feelings for John
Ambrose to herself out of fear of
hurting Peter I thought that if Peter
and I were together the two of us could
get through anything I was wrong but I
do know we weren't honest with each
other and then I haven't been honest
with myself the fallout from their
breakup leads Laura Jean to briefly kiss
John Ambrose at the Bellevue ball in a
moment which feels straight out of one
of the romance novels that LJ loved so
much but this is reality not fantasy and
she quickly realizes she doesn't like
him that way we kissed I I wanted him to
be someone else and stormy helps her
understand that sometimes you have to
kiss
man to know what's right although LJ and
Jonna theoretically more compatible in
terms of their shirt interests outlook
and temperament its Peter who offers
Laura jeans something more and gives her
scope for personal development and
growth as Lana Condor says Lara Jean
needs to be pushed to expand into
different spaces of her personality and
that's what Peter does even though he
presents the risk of breaking her heart
in fact according to the sequel's
director Lara Jean and pieces promise to
never hurt each other was actually
something that was impossible to keep a
youthful but naive vow and when they go
through that in the movie they actually
emerge stronger Peter and I promise not
to break each other's hearts oh honey
you're always breaking someone's harder
they're breaking yours isn't there a way
to both get out unscathed not if you're
doing it right break my heart into a
thousand pieces do whatever you are also
at the heart of the sequel is a
resolution to the question of whether
it's okay to have feelings for more than
one person after her breakup with Peter
Lara Jean realizes as a concept from her
Korean heritage that can help her with
this it's called Cheung it's the
connection between two people that can't
be severed
even when love turns to hate you will
always have tenderness in your heart for
them LJ notices that even though they're
no longer friends
she and Jenn still have chung and she
realizes that peter also has it with Jan
and that she should stop blaming him for
it this moment a self-discovery helps
her reconcile with Genevieve and in the
next scene when Lara Jean sees her
father mrs. Rothschild together she
finally realizes it's possible for him
to find love with someone else but still
hold affection for their mother likewise
by the end of the movie LJ recognizes
that it's possible to love two people at
the same time albeit in different ways
as Lana Condor said in an interview with
E W LJ's deep love for Jong can be
confusing because you like oh man do I
love him or do I love him as a friend
the concept of Cheung tho means that
Laura Jean doesn't have to forsake her
deep affection for John in order to
remain faithful to Peter
campus we've always been or as the
movie's director puts it much of what
the sequel is about is Lara Jean
learning to confront her own truth
without losing her optimistic outlook on
love it's not a cynical view of romance
or either lessons
it's an earnest fun passionate
presentation of it now what do you think
about the sequel and how it handled the
love triangle and are you glad LJ ended
up back with Peter or would you have
preferred John Ambrose comment with your
thoughts below if you enjoyed this be
sure to subscribe for all my new videos
including Netflix is Sabrina you locking
key and stranger things tap left for my
next video or chat right for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time you PK
movie lovers